Speaking of girls'
night out, it's all about
love, isn't there anyone who's in love
?  I have a question for
you What would you like to do if you had a girlfriend
?
Na ua
Eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee Yamaha
[music]
I really
want to make sweets for
you I'm still learning how to cook, so when I become good at it I'd like to feed you
[music]
uc  It wasn't my taste
I ate together and took a bath
together Ah ah  If you don't do it, Noah,
the setting for the other party is only men.
We
go to bookstores together,
then join hands to fight for our country, unleash the darkness that lurks in their hearts, lift
the curse that the wicked witch cast, and the
legendary finger.  I'm looking for and professing the world of uf and
talking about the half of the camera car
.